good morning believe nation today's
message is look yourself in the mirror
over to you Marshall Goldsmith it's very
easy to see what we don't like about
ourselves in other people it's a little
harder to see what we don't like about
ourselves in the mirror and sometimes
other people can see things in us that
we don't want to see in ourselves and
when that happens our first reaction is
you're wrong you're confused people tell
us something we don't want to hear our
first reaction is they're wrong and
they're confused sometimes it's hard to
look in that mirror and say you know
what maybe I'm wrong and maybe I'm
confused what did I learn sometimes
other people can see someone else we
can't see in ourselves and our first
reaction is they're confused a great
challenge learn to listen to other
people hear what they have to say and
recognize sometimes they can see
something in us that we don't want to
see in ourselves so what do you think
you know the first thing that kind of
hit my mind is that the conversations
that we really don't want to have are
the ones that we almost have to have
he's using the analogy of looking
yourself in the mirror and a lot of
times you know that's why I think it's
so important to have coaches and mentors
to have those people in your life that
are willing to kind of call you out and
tell you that you know what maybe you
have some blind spots over here maybe
you have some things that you're not
really you're neglecting or that you're
not really taking care of that last part
it may meet when he was talking about
you know taking things kind of personal
and made me think about the Four
Agreements the Don Miguel Ruiz and one
of them is don't take anything
personally right and so I think for us
that are on this journey of self
development or on this journey of
building our legacy whatever it is we
can gain so much from not taking
anything personally and
actually having coaches and mentors call
us out when we need to be called out
yeah this is an interesting one for me
it's a tough one for me because a lot of
the people who will be telling you what
you should or shouldn't be doing
probably don't want to listen to them
yeah there's a lot of people are gonna
be hating on your idea are telling you
you can't do something and it's really
their own fears and insecurities being
put onto you right like Jay you can't go
do that podcast you can't launch that
YouTube channel that's too ambitious or
too crazy or you know it's really their
fears and and they're telling you the
wrong thing and so I love the importance
of mentorship it's finding the right
person who's actually gonna call you out
on your your own BS or when you're you
know making a mistake but it's probably
not most of the people in your life so
being really selective with who the
people are that you listen to a couple
things that help me when I have a
mastermind group that we meet once a
month and the group of entrepreneurs
we're all you know built businesses and
the more you spend time with them the
more you know they recognize your BS and
your excuses and you're learning beliefs
and they can call you out on it too
watching these videos and learning from
all these people have done way more than
me I feel like their mindset and
approach and their belief systems kind
of seep into me a little bit more and
three just asking myself in the mirror
I've done a number of times where I look
in the mirror and I asked myself like
why can't I be successful at this or why
am I not further ahead and whatever
reason I come up with I realize that
that's really a limiting belief like I'm
not further ahead because I don't have
the resources or I don't have the right
team yet or whatever and it's all just
like I can fix those things and so
asking those questions asking that
specific question why I'm not further
ahead than I am right now in the mirror
I find really helps so the question
today today is do you have any mentors
in your life I like it you have mentors
leave it in the comments below we're
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and they'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go